-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody
doing tonight?
Wally's kid, you good?
Alright.
Can we get you anything?
-[Indistinct]
-Alright. Alright.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden
met with Senate Democrats
at the White House yesterday
and committed to boosting
coronavirus relief checks
to $2,000.
But don't forget, you alread
got a $1,200 one and a $600 one,
plus the standard
20% inflation,
makes it $2,180.
So, basically,
you owe $180.
President Biden spoke at
the State Department today
and gave his first major
foreign policy speech.
Of course, these days,
any speech about policy
feels pretty foreign.
"When's he gonna talk abou
water pressure?
Is that not in today's?"
House Republicans,
last night,
held a five-hour
conference meeting.
Oh, to have been a fly
on literally any other wall.
During last night's House
Republican conference meeting,
GOP members gave
QAnon-supporting congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
a standing ovation --
though, based on
what I know about her,
the smarter move
is to get down.
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy, yesterday,
referred to the conspiracy
theory group QAnon as "Qon,"
and said, quote,
"I don't even know what it is.
Added McCarthy, "Maybe I can ask
Donald Trank? Trimp?
Is it Tramp?
Is that how you say it?
I'll ask him."
That's right --
Kevin McCarthy, yesterday,
referred to the conspiracy group
QAnon as "Qon,"
and said, quote,
"I don't even know what it is.
Ah, the time-tested strategy
of mispronouncing somethin
on purpose
to distance yourself.
He's like a kid
who got caught with weed.
"Oh, this? This is my...
my friend Dave's.
I guess it's marywonka,
or something.
I think it's a spice
from home ec."
Former Housing
and Urban Development secretar
Dr. Ben Carson announced
yesterday that he is launching
a conservative
think tank.
It'll be dedicated
to examining
the pertinent problems
of our time,
and trying to find...
-My luggage.
-Netflix, yesterday, receive
42 Golden Globe nominations.
And when you're working on
your speeches,
you know who to thank.
And finally, the makers of Peeps
have announced
they'll release
two new flavors --
Hot Tamales
and Froot Loops.
And if you think
that's gross,
wait till you see
what you release.
Baze!
That was a monologue.
There he is.
BGaze and Wally's kid,
just living it up.